Doesn't EVERYTHING cause cancer?!
Yes.
It does.
Even Air.
*deep sigh* *oops!*
Breathers [[greet and welcome]]
Yes.
Air.
I know.
Yes.
It sounds stupid, but according to a new study
from PeerJ people who live at elevations closer
to sea level have more tumors than people
who live where the air is thinner!
EVEN OXYGEN GIVES YOU CANCER?
We need oxygen to breathe, but, in breathing
air with more oxygen in it -- we may be triggering
lung cancer formation.
Imperial County, California is 11 meters below
sea level (36ft) and San Juan County, Colorado
is 3473 meters above sea level (2.16m) -- which
means the amount of oxygen can vary as much
as 35 percent depending on where you live!
The two researchers behind the study compared
the rates of numerous cancers across the United
States in counties from purple mountains majesty
to the amber waves of grain, and found a 13
percent increase in lung cancers for every
1,000 meters decrease in elevation!!
That same increase was NOT seen in breast,
colorectal, and prostate cancers.
Before you freak out and try and hold your
breath for the rest of your life, this DOESN'T
mean that oxygen CAUSES cancer; just that
higher levels of elevation correlate with
lower levels of cancer.
In fact, there are a number of other benefits
from living at higher elevations, including
decreased rates of heart disease, better vitamin
D synthesis, and more weight loss to name
a few.
More research is obviously needed, but it
is possible that oxygen is both necessary
for Earth life and slowly killing us.
When we breathe in the oxygen, our cells use
it to harvest energy from food, but part of
the byproduct are oxygen free radicals; called
Reactive Oxygen Species.
Sure they’re natural, but they're also toxic
-- and according to research in the Annual
Review of Genetics, our own ancient mitochondrial
systems might be causing degenerative disease
and cancer!
Which brings me back to the earlier point,
does EVERYTHING cause cancer?
Breathing causes it, making energy from food
causes it, what about food?
My mom would always try to cook her pork chops
with the little black crusty bits on the edges,
because it was DELECTABLE, but she stopped
when she found out the charred bit causes
cancer.
According to the American Cancer Society,
some starchy foods cooked at a high-temperature
will produce acrylamide, a chemical found
in paper, wastewater, adhesives and cigarettes.
Frying bacon, or grilling and smoking meats
can expose food to polycyclic aromatic hydrocarbons,
a chemical known to cause skin, liver, and
stomach cancer in lab animals.
Fried foods have their own problems.
In the end, no serious science recommends
forgoing cooked food, but moderating the amount
of grilled and blackened food is going to
decrease your cancer risk.
AIR.
FOOD.
AND YOUR OWN BODY MAKING THOSE TWO THINGS
INTO ENERGY ALL CAUSE CANCER.
So, relax, exercise and pay attention to what
you're eating, but don't give yourself an
ulcer over it.
We've obviously got enough problems, amirite?